.
Good afternoon everyone.
It’s a pleasure and an honor
to welcome President Dilma Rousseff
who is visiting us for the
first time at Princeton.
It isn’t any secret that
the events in Brazil
since last year make this
visit especially significant.
With the necessary brevity, but searching
for a bit of intellectual honesty
I must say that... I don’t
have my star today...
but I must say that I have great sympathy
for the original proposal that
brought the Worker’s Party
(PT) to power at the beginning
of the last decade,
in a political and economic
process that ended in 2016,
in a decisive moment... and still
indefinite... of Brazilian politics,
with the impeachment of
President Dilma Rousseff.
It isn’t my intention, at
this time and in this space
to defend or critique the
diverse political actors who,
since at least what we call the “jornadas
de 2013” (2013 Protests) in Brazil,
have been confronting a complex
social legacy of the previous decade,
when the Brazilian economy
grew exponentially,
when we saw a still-unrecognized
income distribution in the country,
while, nonetheless, some of its structural
problems were never completely resolved,
like corruption, which is
today the star of the media,
and especially elementary public education.
In one form or another,
the expansion of the internal market and Brazil’s
new place on the international stage seemed,
to many of us Brazilians,
a natural legacy of the Constitution
proclaimed in 1988,
following the most recent
Brazilian dictatorship.
In short, the rights of a society
that was rehearsing its first steps
toward a return to democracy,
are today what we find threatened.
The parliamentary coup
d’etat which brought the
impeachment of President
Dilma Rousseff last year
symbolized the closing of a
cycle in Brazilian history,
or perhaps the opening of another cycle,
in which the judicialization and the spectacularization
(or the mediatization) of Brazilian politics
create an environment of
instability and uncertainty
in relation to the future
of democracy in Brazil.
The worst part of this spectacularization
is probably the lack of dialogue and
the irreversible polarization of positions.
As if there were only two sides,
two enemy tribes.
To make things worse, the
presumed corruptors...
Those that are in prison... are those
that have the most visibility.
A strange situation:
the crooks say what they wish,
and society listens to them,
without the justice system even having
determined the guilt of those who were accused.
The presence of President
Dilma Rousseff today in Princeton
is an effort to give voice to someone who
had her political trajectory interrupted,
which is certainly not
a novelty in her life,
since she, herself,
alongside other leftist militants,
was imprisoned during
the military dictatorship
and lived, last year, a process of
impeachment that made many of us think
in the distance there can be
between legality and legitimacy.
I’d like to thank the colleagues and staff
of the Spanish and Portuguese Department,
Program in Latin American Studies,
and the Princeton Institute for
International and Regional Studies,
who made this event possible,
which is being recorded and simulcast
in other auditoriums on
campus, and also online.
I’d especially like to thank Damaris Zayas,
Rachel Golden, and Justin Kazlauskas for the help
and my colleagues Gabriela Nouzeilles
and Mark Beissinger.
Also thanks to Diogo Santanna,
who served as intermediary for everything,
and my dear colleague and friend at Brown,
James Green.
Last but not least, thanks to the team
of President Dilma Rousseff
It is a great pleasure to invite her
to the stage and, once again,
to give her our most sincere and effusive
welcome to our home.
[Applause]
I wanted to start wishing a good afternoon
to everyone present here,
giving thanks for your presence.
To acknowledge Professor Pedro Meira Monteiro,
Director of the Department of Spanish and Portuguese;
to acknowledge Professor Gabriela Nouzeilles,
from the Program in Latin American Studies;
to acknowledge the Director of the Princeton Institute
for International and Regional Studies, Mark Beissinger;
to acknowledge all of you who made it possible to
be here, to give thanks to all of you present.
During my life, I have
lived two coups d’etat,
One military coup and
one parliamentary coup.
A military coup has certain characteristics
which are basically the
suspension of all rights,
the right to organize, of expression, the
right to mobilize, and freedom of the press,
but above all, the right to dissent.
When you dissent in a military coup,
you’re imprisoned, tortured,
isolated, exiled, and killed.
A parliamentary coup is
different because...
we have to study and understand it...
because it’s a post-Cold War coup,
a coup that has a characteristic:
it doesn’t eliminate certain
democratic rights for all people;
it eliminates rights for some people.
Many have identified the
existence of parliamentary coups,
principally in Latin America,
because in recent years, we can identify
at least three coups d’etat:
one in Honduras, one in Paraguay,
with President Lugo,
and one in Brazil: the impeachment
that took me from power.
These coups are becoming a new way
that popular governments are being
destroyed in Brazil and Latin America.
This is a process for which we have
to understand its raison d’etre,
because understanding and comprehending
is the essential preliminary way
to be able to change a situation.
That’s why I begin telling you
that the parliamentary coup
by virtue of an impeachment
without the crime of responsibility,
was motivated by a few reasons.
I’ll start with a symbolic reason:
the use of a strong misogyny
that characterizes a certain typification
and certain instruments
which are going to be used against me
throughout the process.
I always say
that what is done with words
is very important.
Because what is done with words burdens,
in a democratic society,
part of political and ideological struggle
and a vision of the world
and a vision of society
of questions of gender... really,
of all sorts of questions.
In my case, a dichotomy was visible.
I was seen as a “hard woman.”
Women are “hard.” Men are “strong.”
Women are “susceptible
to emotional crises.”
Men, no. Men are “sensible.”
Women are “obsessive-compulsive”
about their work.
Men are “efficient and determined” workers.
This comes out at times,
sometimes even in coarse language.
This happened throughout the coup,
functioning as its underlying discourse.
It is interesting to note, however,
that for being the first female president,
I was a woman surrounded by kind men.
My male administrative aides, who worked
alongside my female administrative aides
were people who maintained
a non-misogynistic standard.
They maintained a standard of cooperation,
and it is important to note...
Because this makes it clear that Brasil
isn’t just misogyny and gender hatred.
This is an underlying reason,
almost a syntax,
but it isn’t the principal
reason of the coup.
There’s a reason that
also has a characteristic
which mobilizes the
parliamentary part of the coup,
and it’s expressed in the
recording that they made
of the talk between a senator
in favor of the coup, Romero Jucá,
and a senator what was in the process
of being accused, named Sérgio Machado.
In this conversation,
Senator Jucá tells Senator Machado:
“It’s necessary to remove the President because
she’s not going to control Operation Car Wash,
she doesn’t want to impede it, so we need to
remove her from power to “stop the bleeding.”
The word “bleeding” is literal,
“remove me from power” is also literal,
and “impede the
investigations” is explicit.
There was, without any
doubt, this intention,
primarily between those who
politically articulated the coup.
It is also clear that this
is an underlying reason.
Not that it isn’t important...
What I am saying is that, along with other
factors, this creates the reasons for the coup.
But they don’t entirely explain it.
It was necessary for larger interests to
come together in sectors favoring the coup,
of political parties that
made the coup possible.
Which sectors are these?
I would say that in part, it’s the media, which
in Brasil is controlled by four or five families.
And in part, it’s the market.
This conjunction media-market
has an interest.
What is the interest?
To frame Brazil from an economic,
political, and social point of view...
But above all, economic and social...
And I also believe
that there was a strong interest
in framing external Brazilian politics.
The political segment in favor
of the coup, as I said,
was made up in a significant part,
by the PMDB and the PSDB,
federal deputies and senators.
So this group got together
to frame Brazil in what?
To frame Brazil in a neoliberal project
that we had interrupted, which had
been around since (President) Collor,
passing through Fernando Henrique Cardoso,
and had been suspended:
suspended when President Luiz Inácio
Lula da Silva was elected in 2003.
At that time, we discontinued
a process of accelerated privatization
which had occurred, for example, in
Argentina... and will continue to occur.
Argentina is losing its
instruments of finance politics.
Argentina emerges from the crisis, following
the failure of the government of Menem
with the integral loss of the
instruments of the Argentine State.
We maintained three large banks:
one bank, which is the only bank that gives
long-term loans, which is the BNDES,
one comercial bank on the
model of the large private banks,
and one finance bank,
which is the Caixa Econômica Federal,
in addition to maintaining
Petrobras and Eletrobras.
But above all, the capacity
to articulate social policies in Brasil.
To develop social policies.
And this we did.
These policies are characterized
by introducing the poor in the budget.
For carrying out a project
of social inclusion,
the expansion of our internal market...
A country with 200 million inhabitants has
great wealth in its internal market.
And at the same time, guarantee for
the first time in recent years
that there be a politics of social inclusion,
income distribution, and reduction of inequality.
And this wasn’t only the transference
of wealth via the Bolsa Família,
that we have, and which
is very important. Why?
Fourteen million families...
It oscillates entre 13.9 and 14 million...
It is important to say
that these 14 million families
can be multiplied by four, on average,
which makes 56 million people. It isn’t
trivial to make this type of policy.
And it’s important to say that
people don’t live from the Bolsa Família,
which is something reported by the media.
People work. It’s just that
what they make isn’t sufficient.
So the Bolsa Família completes the gap.
And this is the fundamental
idea of the Bolsa Família,
which has requirements,
such as, for example,
Families have to enroll their children
in school... 85% is the minimum diligence
that a family has to take care of its children
in order to maintain the Bolsa Família.
It has to get vaccinations
...three required systematic vaccines...
And, when a woman is pregnant,
she has to carry out
three mandatory pre-natal exams.
This way, we reduced death by diarrhea,
we reduced infant mortality.
But above all, we brought Brazil out of the UN
Hunger Map in 2014... between 2013 and 2014.
And we overcame extreme poverty in 2014,
when we exceeded the limit,
which we considered,
which was $1.50 per day,
so that no Brazilian was below this.
It’s something important.
But it wasn’t just this that we did.
No process of income distribution
exists without access to public services
and without increased
opportunities for people
in terms of their own education
and ability to find better work.
We are talking about assuring certain access to
differentiated productive activities. Through what?
Through professional education.
It was a program we called Pronatec,
The National Program of Technical
Education and Employment.
We constructed this program, in
partnership with other industrial services,
services of industrial
education, the SENAI,
which is a service that trains
industry workers...
By the way, Preident Lula became a metal worker
because he had been trained at SENAI.
So we formed this partnership with the SENAI,
with the National Service of Agriculture,
with the National Transportation Service,
and with our Federal Institutes of
Technological Instruction,
and we formed this partnership.
We trained 20 million people.
Becuase in Brazil it's important to say:
We broke with the previos project which
enacted social policy through pilot programs.
But enacting social policy through pilot programs,
in a country with 200 million inhabitants,
100 million of whom are poor,
means not doing anything.
So, when we see the curve of
income distribution in Brazil,
of income distribution and of inclusion,
you’ll see that the periods of pilot
programs are periods of stagnation,
there’s no effect on poverty.
We have to make policies in Brazil
for millions of people.
So there’s no policy.
And this is something very important,
which is that people
changed their perspective.
We have to remember that Brazil was the
last country to abolish slavery.
I always say this because
it’s important for understanding Brazil.
We have a problem with social inclusion
and we have a problem with privilege.
There are segments of society
that think that it’s their privilege,
for example, to enjoy the airports,
without being disrupted by
domestic workers and doormen,
or other professional categories that before didn’t
travel in plane and started to travel in plane.
But that’s just a detail.
The fact is, we did this.
The coup, for me, was a planned process.
Planned also because we were
going against the grain:
when inequality was increasing
in the rest of the world,
in Brazil it was decreasing.
All you have to do is
look at the Gini index.
However, we didn't manage to take
all the necessary steps.
so that along with income distribution,
we could change wealth distribution.
We partially achieved
more equal distribution of wealth,
because we created programs that guaranteed
access to housing for the poorest population.
In truth, I think that the
biggest factor of the coup
is that it was inimaginable for the poor
to form part of the budget.
We had done something... and I don’t
consider it an absurd alteration,
a radical alteration in the system...
But it was an expressive step, because for the first
time there was really income distribution in Brazil,
for the first time, there were social
policies, any government policy had a focus:
“We have to overcome poverty,
we have to overcome supreme poverty,
We have to guarantee access
to quality public services.”
This is so important.
I’m going to say this because I met
a student of Cuban origin here.
Because I want to speak about
“Mais Médicos” (More Doctors),
and I’m grateful to the Cuban doctors, and to the Cuban
government for having sent to Brazil 11,000 doctors.
Brazil was a country that had 1.8 doctors
for every 1,000 inhabitants,
below the standards set by
the World Health Organization.
From there, we tried to grow and we created
many problems with the medical segments
because of the problem of privilege.
And we brought to Brazil 18,260 doctors,
which made it possible to
attend 63 million Brazilians.
Where? Not over there in the Amazon...
There too... but also in the periphery of
the largest city in Brazil, São Paulo,
in the periphery of the largest Brazilian cities, the
capitals, cities larger than 100,000 inhabitants.
Using what? The same database that was
used in the process for the Bolsa Família
served also to cross medical assistance
with the database registrar.
You can observe that we
distributed privileging
where the population had the greatest need because
they have the greatest socio-economic fragility.
Now... all that couldn’t be this way.
It had to end.
So what happens? The
economic crisis begins.
Nobody can do anything... we succeeded for six years
at preventing the crisis from arriving to us.
One thing is governing
at the rise of a cycle.
Another thing is governing
when the crisis begins,
because the crisis stirs up
something they call distributive conflict.
You’ll remember that in Brazil,
on the eve of impeachment,
it was substantiated by the yellow duck,
there on the Avenida
Paulista, a six-meter duck,
that was an undue copy of a Dutch duck,
that they placed on the Avenida Paulista,
the financial center of São Paulo,
saying “I don’t want to pay the duck.” That is,
“pay the duck,” in a distributive conflict,
is to pay the necessary part of the crisis,
which is an increase in taxes.
There is no way to just cut costs,
Europe is proving this, ad nauseam. Why?
Because what happens
with austerity policies?
You cut, cut, cut spending, you depress
the economy instead of restarting it.
In Brazil, we needed to adapt. In crisis,
you always need to readjust spending.
How, then, to increase taxes at the same time,
which in Brazil is a completely regressive system?
Because it’s a difficult thing
to pass tax reform in Congress.
We tried three times, and then we started
sending isolated adjustments.
And the last one we sent was the CPMF,
which is a tax of 0.38% on
financial transactions,
which caused horror for the elite, because it
would make clear where tax fraude was happening.
That’s why the CPMF was
battled and transformed
into one of the greatest threats to
civilization committed by my government.
The threat was precisely realizing that
we had already charged a greater CPMF.
It was realizing that (and we had
already changed the CPMF before)
the internal revenue service, from
taxing all financial transactions,
knows who’s paying what for whom.
So it was a very complex process.
I want to say that the media played an
important role in distorting the facts.
The media said Brazil was broken:
“This government needs to leave
because it left Brazil broken.”
Now, this government that
“left Brazil broken”
was the government that
prevented Brazil from defaulting
with the International Monetary Fund (FMI),
which permitted that in 2002,
when we arrived to the government,
the FMI dictated Brazil’s
macro-economic policy.
We payed off the Fund around 2006,
I believe that it was at
the beginning of 2006.
Why? Because the government before Lula
had only $14 billion in reserves
and owed $16 billion to international
creditors, if I’m not mistaken.
Anyway, we payed off the Fund.
But in the period of 2003
until the day I left the government,
we accumulated $380 billion in reserves.
No country is “broken” if
it pays its creditors.
We didn’t simply pay our creditors, we had
enough money to honor our commitments.
“The government is broken”...a government
isn’t broken if it honors its debt,
if it has the capacity to go into debt
and to charge taxes.
So the government broke the country?
The government didn’t break the country.
The government faced an economic crisis
that became the basis for a political
crisis. That is what happened.
The government faced an economic crisis
and suffered a political crisis.
Why? Because we had a program.
We won four elections with that program.
In this past election, it became clear,
because they believed until the last minute
that they were going to win,
but in the past election it became clear
that they hadn’t won the elections.
So what’s the situation?
Four consecutive times they had
lost the opportunity to adopt the program
that they considered best for Brazil,
which is a neoliberal conservative program
which believes that we spend
too much on the poor.
So much so that they called... until the moment they
realized the population didn’t share their view...
They called the Bolsa Família the “Bolsa
Esmola” (the Charity Scholarship),
until the moment they realized that they had created an
enormous campaign against the arrival of the doctors,
until they realized that the doctors
had the support of the population,
90% of the population supports
the presence of the doctors
and even says that they are very important because
“they take care of us, they check in, they do exams,
and they have a closer relationship.”
And this is really good because it
changes the standard of service.
Besides, they praise the doctors a lot.
I also want to record here
that they say Brazilian nurses
have great professionalism and a great capacity for
service, but going back to what I was saying...
So, if Brazil wasn’t broken,
if it wasn’t the government, if it wasn’t the
policies of the government, what was it?
“We’re against the policies of the government,
we can’t wait until the election.”
So they created they conditions and
the environment for impeachment.
How do you create the
environment for impeachment?
It’s interesting to signal what
an author named Naomi Klein says.
She says the following, citing Friedman,
and citing Friedman’s
evaluation of two circumstances:
One, the government of Pinochet (in Chile) and
two, the Falklands crisis for Margret Thatcher.
She basically says the following:
It is very important when you’re in a moment of crisis,
because in crisis... I’m going to quote literally:
“Only a crisis... actual or perceived...
Produces real change.
When that crisis occurs, the actions that are
taken depend on the ideas that are lying around.
That, I believe, is our basic function:
to develop alternatives
to existing policies,
to keep them alive and available
until the politically impossible
becomes the politically inevitable.”
The politically imposible was,
through the electoral process
to pass through the neoliberal reforms
that are now being imposed.
They would never be approved.
They were never approved,
they were not even mentioned.
This is the politically impossible.
The politically inevitable is when a political crisis
on top of an economic crisis, creates impeachment.
This is the trajectory and the prescription
of the coup in Brazil.
It was about framing Brazil in
neoliberalism, and they did it.
So I tell you here, concluding.
This process is a process that is contradictory
today with the interests of the population.
Why? After the impeachment,
they tried to limit the debt ceiling
which ends up freezing for 20 years
spending on education and health.
In real terms, the rest of the
spending a primary budget exemptions
could even have nominal reduction.
They propose a welfare reform,
which is the reform of a model
in which if you complete the
requirements for integral retirement,
if you retire, you have
to start working at age nine.
Why? It’s 65 years plus
49 years of service.
49 years of service in a labor market with unemployment
and informality, you have seven more years, on average.
Add 49 and 7, it makes 56, subtract
from 65, you get nine years old.
It’s not evil, it’s changing the model.
It’s getting rid of public welfare,
creating the conditions
to privatize welfare.
But in the interim, it destroys retirement
for women, rural workers, men, the poor,
it gets ride of assistance
for the poor and disabled.
It creates job insecurity
with the law they call outsourcing,
it increases deregulation of the job market,
creating job insecurity and diminishing salaries
now through a project that
wants to do away with
the Consolidation of Labor Laws (CLT),
of workers’ protections.
Anyway, it opens up land to foreigners, opens
the skies to aviation without a counterbalance
it’s selling parts of the pre-salt layer
at rather questionable prices...
and all of this is happening.
What’s the contradiction? The more they do
this to serve the media and the market,
the more the population reacts against
them, and there they have a conflict.
There’s an election in 2018.
The conflict is the following:
If it serves the market, the congresspeople
who aren’t suicidal
(they might be something else,
but they aren’t suicidal)
they won’t vote in such unpopular measures.
If they don’t vote, they won’t deliver
service to the market.
If they vote... the congresspeople
who aren’t suicidal...
There’s no proof of the
measures they need to deliver.
That’s the dilemma.
Besides that, even though they had promised that they would
freeze the investigations so they wouldn’t reach them
they reached them.
So, the situation in Brazil
today only has one solution.
That old story that it’s possible to talk,
to have dialogue, is a fairy tale.
No one can think that in a country
with the complexity of Brazil,
everybody is going to sit down and talk.
Where do we talk in a democracy?
In the election we talk.
So, the only way to get out of this crisis
in which we find ourselves is the election.
Be that when it is, it’s a
scheduled meeting in a democracy.
If it isn’t before, we know that
there’s a date scheduled: October of 2018.
And October of 2018 in
Brazil already began.
Why? Because the national
campaign mobilizes all interests.
It’s like this here too. Presidential
regimes have this characteristic.
I believe that the only way out for Brazil is democracy,
more democracy, and greater extension of freedoms.
And remembering always that we have
only transformed a country successfully
when we’ve had democracy.
They’ve been the richest periods.
Thank you very much.
Everyone can hear, right?
We’re going to move to the questions.
We have approximately 20-25 minutes.
Believe me that it’s not an easy task
to cut off the President...
but I think this way,
we’ll have a little time.
The organization we had discussed
is that we are going to
collect a few questions
so there’s more time for the
voice to be with you all.
I’m going to use my prerogative as moderator
to ask the first question very quickly,
which is, simply: Mrs. President,
for us to get beyond the idea
of the inevitability of the coup,
how can we think about
and understand retrospectively
the 2013 protests in Brazil?
There are microphones in the audience.
Who would like to ask one
or two more questions?
We have several candidates.
Let me take notes.
Hi Mrs. President. I’d like to
thank you for your presence here.
My name is Rafael. I’m a student here
in the Woodrow Wilson School
and I worked in management for Minister Miriam
Belchior and Ministrer José Eduardo Cardozo.
I was hoping you could comment on the electoral success of
certain politicians who call themselves “non-politicians” or
“professional administers” and what this
means for Brazilian democracy.
The other thing we’ve seen this week
is the disclosure of a list of almost 100 names of
politicians and governors, current ministers, senators,
who are being prosecuted in the federal Supreme Court for
accusations that vary from fraud to money laundering.
I was hoping you could comment on
the necessary political reforms
to help recover the credibility
of Brazilian politicians.
One more?
Good afternoon. My name is Vinícius.
I’m a doctoral student here in Physics.
Thank you very much for visiting us.
My question is related to something you
mentioned during your talk about the BNDES
and about the central role that
developmentalism had in your government
and in the construction of
infrastructure in Brazil.
Some people criticize the fact that Brazil
took external loans at 14% and then BNDES,
to stimulate the economy, would
give cheap loans at 3%,
and that this would have created
a large financial imbalance.
So I wanted to know your opinion
with respect to this,
about the role of the State as
a driver of development.
Should we start with these?
We’ll go fast.
We’re going to wait for the answers
before another round of questions.
2013. There are many explanations.
It’s something that
always raises questions.
But I have one of the reasons.
I think that it’s much easier to distribute
income than to guarantee access to services.
You distribute income, in ten years
you change the pattern significantly...
It isn’t easy
to create a new technology for this.
We used the state bank "Caixa" to be able to distribute
cards, therefore getting rid of clientelism,
preventing a direct relationship between any person
and the citizen who received the Bolsa Família.
But it’s difficult to access,
to change the quality of services.
To change all of the social
infrastructure of a country.
To guarantee medical posts near people.
You all need to see that one of the strong
motivations for mobilization in 2013 was health.
One of them was health.
That’s why we created Mais Médicos
and we brought doctors from abroad.
But the situation is difficult. Why?
Because let’s be clear about something:
The end of extreme poverty is
only the beginning, as we’d say.
The end of extreme poverty
doesn’t resolve anything.
On the contrary, from there,
people have other interests,
they have other claims, they have other
desires, other demands, other anxieties.
Here’s something I think had a part in 2013
and which is due to this yearning for more.
And I also believe that there’s
something interesting about Brazil.
There’s an institute called “Data Popular”
that ran an investigation about what
you attribute a change in your life to.
In the first place, God.
In the second place, the person, him
or herself... which is very good.
In the third place, the person’s family.
In the fourth place, a few friends,
and in the last place, the government.
I’m saying this because it isn’t only my
information, it didn't happened only in Brazil.
I had a conversation recently with
ex-President Cristina Kirchner
and she tells that me in Argentina
the pattern of response is very similar.
What does this mean?
It means that governments
can’t stop doing things,
explaining why they are
doing certain things.
Principally because when they’re large-scale
policies, it isn’t clear what is being done.
So there was dissatisfaction
toward access to services. Very strong.
I also think that at that time,
there was a theory that it was
legitimate democratic expression.
That’s how we confronted it at the time.
We treated it as something necessary,
something correct.
I don’t think 2013 had anything
to do with 2016 and 2015.
Why? Because in 2013, Brazil was growing.
The interest rate had reached 2.5%.
The unemployment rate was falling.
So immediate economic reasons,
there weren’t any.
But I think there was
social dissatisfaction
caused by improvements in quality of life
and greater necessity for change.
That’s why I think that
2013 has a component
that is a positive component,
not a negative component.
I believe that the resurgence of the idea of
"the worse the better" doesn’t come in a vacuum.
It’s not a flash in a blue sky.
It’s human-powered.
And here I move to the second (question).
They choose a president of the Chamber,
a president of the Chamber who changes...
And I’ll move also to the other question...
Who changes the democratic
center of Brazil.
You have a democratic center that emerges
from the Constitution of 1988
of which Dr. Ulysses Guimarães, aka "Democratic
Elections Doctor," holds its maximum expression.
So you have a pattern with Brazil’s
center being progressive.
And besides being progressive, it participated
in one form or another in all governments.
All the presidential
coalitions of the moment.
Beginning at a certain moment,
there’s a rupture in this center.
Its hegemony shifts to a
position on the extreme right,
ultraconservative from
the point of view of civilization,
and representative of the “Bancada da
Bala,” of the “Boi” (the “BBB Bench”).
It’s BBB, right? Bullet,
bullock, and bible.
Those three.
And there are gender politics
that are very bad.
Homophobic politics,
besides being ultra ultra conservative
and neoliberal.
This political hegemonization
invalidated my government,
four months after being elected.
March. I was elected in November. In March, they
already brought to the table the idea of impeachment.
From there, politics in terms of
worse and better is visible.
The enterprise called it
the “Pauta-Bomba” (Bombs Away!).
It was the agenda that
increased spending instead of reducing.
So I don’t think it had
anything to do with 2013
but I think that ascending
technocratic politics
have plagued Brazil since the dictatorship.
This politics they call technocratic,
something above good and evil, and that
we have to elect technocratic leaders,
Comes from the dictatorship.
The dictatorship created this,
in that old discussion that a student
was for studying, a teacher for teaching
a worker for working, and politics
was carried out by a military government.
So this process by a technocratic
government, apolitical and not ideological,
that is the vision. And I think
this is very serious.
Because I think that anyone who defends
one of these positions isn’t democratic.
Democracy is born for politics.
You can’t separate one from the other. Why?
Because without a political vision
in the sense of defending interests,
not my individual interests, but
the collective interests of a society,
you don’t have a democratic process.
There’s no given form by the economy
nor by any economic, sociological,
or political theory
that guarantees the correct
management of men and women.
There is only one way:
politics, conscience,
opposition, and participation.
So, technocracy is a very
questionable form of domination
that I think emerges today
from the following contradiction:
neoliberalism, increasing inequality,
and increasing restrictions.
It’s a form of corroding democracy.
One of the variables is technocracy.
To say that it’s possible
to look in the manual,
and get rid of participation of the
people with their votes, or to take
care of the public sphere technocratically,
is impossible to carry out democratically.
In any dictatorship, this is a no-brainer.
The list... So what happens?
The list isn’t of 81 people.
The list is of 300 people.
They’re being sent to investigation.
They’re not being prosecuted.
What’s the problem?
Many problems come out of this.
I’m not going to tell here.
I really should, so I’m going to.
You know why I should tell? Because it shows
a certain pattern for you to understand.
During one year, two
people from my campaign,
one was the treasurer, and another was
the person who became my chief of staff,
were accused of having gone to the CEO
of a company called Andrade Gutierrez,
the CEO was named Otávio Azevedo. I’m saying
the names because they’re public record.
He said that these members of my campaign,
had gone there and threatened:
“If you don’t contribute to the campaign,
you won't get any contracts.”
No position in the government.
This is how it was taken.
So the judge... a little more
than a year went by...
And the judge calls this man
to testify, and asks,
and the defense attorney also asks,
“When was this?” He says the date.
“And how was it done?”
With a nominal cheque.
“What day was it?” He gives the date.
If I’m not mistaken,
it was a 10th or a 14th.
The people from the campaign go
check the records,
because it was an official action.
Bribe and blackmail,
that was the only charge.
So they go there and
discover the following:
There was, in fact, a donation and
there was, in fact, a nominal cheque.
For whom was the donation?
It was for the PMDB.
Why did he think it was for the PT?
Because the in the court classification, the last number
of the process was 13 [number of the Workers' Party, PT].
Wait, be calm. You
think it stopped there?
If it were only that, we
would have been condemned.
So he looks for the nominal cheque...
And this is all online.
It was published in all the newspapers,
by Jânio de Freitas, nonetheless.
So they look at the nominal cheque.
To whom is it made out?
Michel Temer.
So then we told the judge:
“Cancel the accusation,
"call out the person who had pressed
charges, this is perjury.”
So the judge calls the person
who had pressed charges
and asks him:
“Here is the evidence,
do you have anything to say?”
And he says, “Oops, I was mistaken.”
The defense says, "How is it possible
that you made a mistake,
"if you said for a year that this was corruption?"
"You said it was. Now it isn’t corruption anymore?
We would like to know if it was corruption."
He hadn’t just been mistaken,
but this wasn’t corruption.
It hadn’t happened. No one went and
looked for him in his office.
And this is what I’m saying:
A lot of things are pushed through quickly.
When you treat some people, it’s
according to certain criteria
and when you treat others,
it’s different criteria.
I think it’s very strange that
during those two and a half years
The accused have only been from the PT.
Only.
Now it’s imposible for everyone else
not to be investigated too.
I want to tell you all,
I want to say this because it’s
been broadcast to Brazil as well,
that with me, they use a trick
which is the following:
“She knew.” And then you ask,
“But did you tell her this?”
“No I didn’t, but she should have known.”
“But how should she have known?”
And here it’s the judge asking:
“How should she have known? Why?”
Because of the size of my enterprise.
So they accuse me. They can’t accuse
me of having given money.
They can’t accuse me of having
a Swiss bank account
of money in any other fiscal paradise.
They can’t accuse me of having accepted
ANY illegal action.
Now, accusations of the sort,
“She should have known”
I’ve had since the day of my election.
On the day of my election, the cover
of the magazine Veja read:
“She knew everything.”
It didn’t specify what was this
“everything” nor what I “knew.”
The advantage now is that
this is going to be opened up.
And just like we discovered the
nominal cheque and the account,
we’ll discover what type of story this is.
So I think I've finished...
Ah, and Vinícius and infrastructure.
Vinícius, terrible news: they’re
destroying the BNDES.
The BNDES is being destroyed.
First they went and took
$100 billion from the BNDES.
Why? How does the BNDES work?
Part of the BNDES obtains resources;
it has shares, it
participates in companies.
All this creates cash flow.
Another part is that the union government
increases its participation.
It increases the quantity of resources
that it sends to the BNDES
to be able to make loans.
It was always like this
and always worked like this.
One of the things that allowed us to have
fairly high economic growth in this period
wasn’t for us, it was from
financing activities.
From small activities
to more sophisticated ones.
And this was done with the BNDES.
I think the BNDES is a
fundamental instrument of development.
For you to have an idea, the resources of the BNDES
were of the size of the resources of the World Bank.
The BNDES isn’t a little bank. Many times bigger
than the Inter-American Development Bank.
In terms of resources, very
close to the World Bank.
In this period, the
government didn’t take loans,
not from the BID, nor from the World Bank.
We left the BID and the World Bank
for states and regional
governments, if necessary.
Starting in 2007-2008, we never took
any more resources because we had them.
Brazil is a rich country.
Believe me that what they’re
doing is the following:
they are constructing a new brutal recession
because they believed in their own story.
First, they believed that the economic crisis
was due to the PT being in the government
and not because there was a huge drop
in the price of commodities.
You had the United States leaving the TPP, provoking
a generalized crisis in emerging countries.
In Brazil, we were still feeling the
effects of the recession in China.
China is an important economy
for emerging countries.
And Brazil went through its
biggest hydrological crisis...
We’re still at the end of it...
In the past 80 years.
We had drought for a long time
where had never been drought,
which was in São Paulo, in the
southeast of the country.
And this provoked an extreme
situation of inflation,
because we had to drop the
price of thermal energy.
We use more water. You don’t pay for water.
When you use thermal energy,
you pay for fuel, and fuel is expensive.
This had repercussions in
prices and in inflation.
And finally, what I think
is most significant
is that they underestimated the
political crisis they created,
which is very serious.
Mrs. President, we are unfortunately out
of time, as we are aware.
But I’d like to ask just one last question
to be able to close,
and the question is very simple,
and from the bottom of my heart.
Thinking about Brazil, and the future,
and not thinking only about 2018,
although we’re all tempted to think
about a big change in 2018,
how to be optimistic today
and recover utopia?
I don’t think 2018 will bring a big change.
I think 2018 is something else.
Brazil has a tradition of
making transitions on top.
I’ll give the the last one,
but we could cite several.
In the last one, despite the movement
in support of free elections after the dictatorship,
when there would be a democratic transition,
a renegotiation was made.
And I’m not saying here that
it should have been different.
I think we cannot do that with history.
It was like that.
It was like that. What did they do?
They negotiated torture. The torturers
were going to get amnesty.
There were many arguments that if you didn’t
do this, a transition wouldn’t be possible.
Nobody will ever know.
The fact is that we’re different
from Argentina, Chile, and Uruguay,
which didn’t give amnesty to torturers
and prosecuted them.
The consequence of this
is that it’s possible
for a person to go inside Parliament to
defend the military dictatorship and torture
in a vote for impeachment.
And others invade the parliament and
defend the return of a military dictatorship.
This would be unthinkable in Chile,
Uruguay, and Argentina.
Anyway, I don’t think it’s possible today
to make a transition on top.
A transition on top is a
transition of the elite.
I think that always in a transition,
there has to be a base in which all the people
and leaders participate.
I understand that.
I just think that at this time,
there has to be a democratic process
as the basis of any transition.
Any negotiation, any dialogue,
if you want to use the word.
Any dialogue.
There will never be dialogue,
because it isn’t possible to have dialogue,
without a democratic process.
I don't think it's a return to power,
or to remain there.
I just believe the following:
Without a democratic process
with participation by the population...
And win whoever wins,
the result must be respected.
This is the only possible way
to have a transition.
The democratic process for me is much more,
the detonator of a process that will
allow Brazil to retake a path.
If it’s going to be 2018?
It’s the deadline.
I don’t know when it’s going to occur,
it will depend on the country’s situation.
But I think that there’s
a date scheduled in 2018.
And from this effect, alongside the process,
comes another thing: political reform.
Because a country with 25
parties is ungovernable.
It’s not that people aren’t virtuous.
They might even not be very virtuous.
But the electoral system,
the political system,
triggers non-virtue.
Why? Because 25 parties
can’t have a program.
I’m sorry, but there are not
25 programs for Brazil.
And it’s not 25, it will
be 30 very soon.
Why? Because they got rid
of the electoral threshold,
so two democratic clauses,
which are free access to communication
media during the electoral period,
which gets rid of the media filter,
and the public party fund
that gives support,
those two are obviously used
for the expansion of parties.
If the party is free, and I’m
going to have access to the party fund,
and I can negotiate time on TV,
I can aim at what I want for the party.
Since I am never going to be in power
because I’m from a tiny party,
what do I do?
I negotiate positions, I negotiate amendments,
I negotiate advantages.
So it has to do with the process
of ungovernability in Brazil.
This is where (and I don’t know how you
translate physiology in the United States)
Or patronage.
Do you know how to translate it?
I think it already entered into
the vocabulary, didn’t it?
Yes. This is a process
that the system fosters.
So two things have to occur.
The democratic process, you never know...
you never know what comes
out of the judge’s head.
It used to be said that you never know
what comes from a judge's head...but you know.
From a woman’s womb, you also know.
But the electoral process you
never know what will come.
You can’t know. It’s impossible.
And also, at this stage, to say that
democracy is a threat...
I already mentioned this story I'd heard in the past.
Democracy is not a threat!
At this moment, democracy is
the only way to structure a process
that didn’t work out, which is the
impeachment process,
the coup, and the
consequences of the coup.
The absolute paralysis today of Brazil
facing everything that is happening.
They’re not giving anything, they’re not
even delivering anything to the market.
We’re in a rather difficult situation.
So I say for you here:
I believe that in the democratic process
there’s no shame in losing the election.
There’s no shame in the election
for whoever wins and whoever loses.
What’s wrong is losing the election
and wanting to win by other means.
That’s what’s wrong.
So for me, the democratic
process is eminently...
Now, they can’t create a coup
in a democratic process.
The democratic process's aim is
for us to find ourselves.
Because nobody can start saying
after an election,
“But I don’t want that president,
I want the other one”
Because if not, you shake things up
and then there’s a coup.
So on top of this, on top of
the democratic process
you make a pact.
Because I don’t think,
and you’ll excuse me...
I already told this story yesterday,
I always remember a cartoon I read
of Asterix and Obelix.
There’s the centurion mounted on the horse,
pensive and reflective,
and he says the following:
“I think these Welsh are really strange.
“We invade their country,
“We destroy their towns
“We kill them, we rape their women,
“And when we want dialogue,
they don’t want to talk.”
I’m so sorry, but in order to
have dialogue today in Brazil,
you have to have popular participation.
There is no dialogue on top possible.
There’s an agreement. What is it?
The agreement is the following:
We are going to have direct elections.
We are going to make political reform.
I think this agreement
is absolutely necessary.
Now, dialogue is dialogue.
First and foremost, you have to have
a basis of democracy.